what's up guys this is mark i'm here
with buzzfeed and we're going to read
some thirst tweets i'm kind of scared
oh all right let's start
mark twain has abs i am weak i'm goodbye
okay i don't have abs i feel like they
only show sometimes in certain pictures
that's not that's not too bad sweaty
mark twain really hit my ovaries
differently
i don't get that sweaty on stage unless
i'm wearing like
super thick jackets i don't know what to
say
thank you or
that's supposed to be a compliment right
i'm kind of scared to open all these
okay mark twain if you lick your lips
one more time sir i will be forced to
marry you that's kind of a bad habit of
mine licking my lips i've been more
conscious about it like trying not to do
it i don't know if i'm gonna lick my
lips during this video but if i do i
guess you'll be forced to marry me
okay i think i just lick my lips but i'm
sorry you know how people would drink a
whole soda can and then put it on the
ground and stomp it that's what i want
mark twain to do to me
i used to do that i used to stop on soda
cans i wouldn't want to do that to you
um i don't want to break anything yeah i
think we won't we won't do any stopping
on anybody i'm willing to train my soul
in exchange
to mark twan's sweaty towel please let
me have it i do throw my towels um at
the crowd at the concerts so maybe one
day
i don't know why you guys would want
that i mean wouldn't it
it's
stink i wouldn't want anybody sweaty
towels mark twan fact had to
excuse me while i go
pharaoh what does it mean to go feral i
just like the placement i don't know if
that triggers anybody like to go
feral but
i guess everybody has their own
preference right pretending to read
but is actually thinking about mark
twain's pink pepperoni nipples
whoa okay i don't show my nipples that
often there are some pictures out there
pepperoni
these get worse right yes i'm saying i
would like mark twain sweaty pits and
what about it some of you guys are
pretty pretty wild licking and licking
anybody's sweaty pits um
i'm not too sure about that
[Music]
okay mark on who his nipple is my new
bias why are you guys so obsessed with
nipples the makeup artist and
hairstylist is laughing right now
sexualizing the members and tweeting
thirst tweets
and all need to stop like imagine one of
the boys seeing them it would be so
embarrassing okay
now that they stopped reading mark twain
eat me like a zombie
you're crazy
how many hey zaddy's dms will it take
for markton to answer me i don't know
how many you sent but
you made it here
mark twain come here let me eat your ass
i think that might have been the worst
one right now that's not sanitary guys
marked on best [ __ ] i never understood
what this word meant
okay that's what it is um
thank you i want my trunk to sit on my
face and choke me with his thighs my man
looked so good i feel like my thighs are
pretty skinny unlike jackson and jb they
are like muscle thighs she said i look
good so thank you mark twain the type to
be dominant but submissive on special
occasions like your birthday this isn't
that bad is it i don't know if i'm
dominant don't give off that kind of lie
do i only sometimes when i get angry i
guess daddy mark twain sir i'm just the
whole and what do you mean by that what
do you
what do you want
mark twain the type to destroy your
vagina in the most romantic way bye
mark twain put your amazing arms around
my neck and then choke me i definitely
wouldn't want to choke you maybe
some other people would but
oh not me martunka spit on me and i'd
say thank you i am not this type of
person that you guys
are imagining or picturing i mean maybe
it's like on tour you know like
accidentally i'm singing and
you know some bit comes out
that's the only way but
i wouldn't spit on any of you guys i
like my shower as i like mark twain
relaxing hot and making me wet
licking my lips i've been more conscious
about it licking
[Music]
choke me please exfutiate me make sure
there is no air going in or out of my
lungs wrap your hands around my throat
and squeeze me until i can't speak and
make a sound there's a lot of
tweets asking to be choked i wouldn't
want any of you guys to have to risk
your life or anything so i'll pass on
these i do not want children but i do
want raw sex with mark twain if he
impregnates me and fertilizes my eggs
then too bad for him i'd accept to be a
mom safe sex everybody save sex
i want to have sex with mark twain until
the room stinks
yeah he's cute in his body
muy bien i want to use his
facial moisture
[Music]
i don't know if that's good for your
skin weaving for you but i wouldn't want
to use it as
a face moisturizer i mean i've
definitely
seen like a couple tweets before here
and there but nothing like this i'm
really curious on what's going through
their mind when they're typing this
it's just i guess how much they love me
so
thank you everybody thank you buzzfeed
and thank you everybody for your third
streets i'm gonna be on tour starting
october so if you guys are gonna be
there i'll see you guys soon and i hope
you guys enjoy the album i'll just
forget all this and move on with my day
why do you guys like nipples that much
[Music]
[Music]
you